just walking down the longest scariest
hall ever has anyone ever not died of a
messy stabbing death in this hallway
Jesus okay we're back in the hallway
again never-ending scary hallway better
wrought security with me this time I
brought Haley yeah she's the muscle of
this operation what a lot of people
don't know is that this entire hallway
has been constructed out of congealed
hepatitis so it makes for a surprisingly
sturdy cinderblock so something new
every day right you know hey everybody
it's Charlie hepatitis walls you learn
something new every day there's actually
a ton of Deadpool updates Deadpool 2 in
the Deadpool animated series we actually
have a premiere date for that so I'll
break down what's going on because the
writers also clarified where they're
pulling from when they wrote the
episodes so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I'm still trying to think
of a Deadpool theme to give away so if
there's anything specific because there
will be 10 episodes of the Deadpool
series so if there's like a specific
Deadpool thing that you think I should
use for that giveaway just let me know
in the comments but as you can see from
Ryan Reynolds walking down scary
hallways in his Deadpool costume with
tiny bodyguards
they're still doing work on the Deadpool
2 movie he's just on a studio lot there
just going from set to set punching up
jokes scenes even Josh Brolin said that
he's gonna be doing work on the movie
right up until the last minute the movie
is not till May 18th they won't start
their actual press tour till like maybe
four to six weeks before that so you'll
continue to see more behind the scenes
stuff like this as they drop new
trailers I'm not expecting a really big
new trailer till March Madness though
just because that's like a really big
sporting event in the United States if
you don't live in the United States
basketball pretty big deal so anytime
there's a really big tournament all the
studios dumped a bunch of footage so
that also means new infinity war maybe
some new ant-man and the wasp footage
too there's also some mysterious
infinity war event happening on Good
Morning America tomorrow morning so if
they drop new footage for that of course
I'll do a video but the Deadpool TV
series I was
through interviews with people who were
writing the show just finding out what
they were saying about it how it was
gonna feel what the tone was gonna be
where they were pulling from in the
comics in caught that it was actually
supposed to premiere during May which is
way earlier than I expected because
animation takes a long time and if you
didn't know it's FXX which is gonna
premiere this series so think like
Archer the same network that does Archer
is going to be doing this animated
Deadpool series Lana but I don't know
who the animation studio is so I can't
tell you what the animation is gonna
look like yet and that's gonna be a
pretty big deal people just want to see
what it looks like and find out who the
voice cast is if the movies coming out
May 18th and if these press outlets that
are reporting that the series is gonna
premiere in May I'm just assuming that
it's gonna be like a week or two after
the movie drops and they'll be like hey
you just saw this giant Deadpool movie
with Ryan Reynolds now watch ten
episodes of this awesome Deadpool series
so of course I'll do videos for all
those episodes just like I would do for
Rick and Morty or any of the other
animated series that I do on my channel
I've been wanting to do some more
animation but it's just a matter of
finding the right series that fits with
a lot of the other content that I make
so Deadpool seems like a really solid
match Young Justice season 3 will be
like the next big animated series that I
do videos for later this year but that's
not premiering to like the very end of
the year one of the writers gave an
interview she said that they are being
more true to the comics than they are to
the movies like the movies changed quite
a bit you saw that first Deadpool movie
they did his origin story they changed
that quite a bit you finally had to [ __ ]
it promise you'll do right by me so I
can do right by someone else
of course please don't make the
supersuit green or animated so if you're
a big fan of any of the Deadpool comics
then the TV series will be right down
your alley but she says I don't think we
took many cues from the movie or what
the general public knows about Deadpool
I think we sort of lean into the comic
books we're like this is how we
interpret this person in this character
this superhero this antihero and sort of
may that apply to the TV that we love in
our lives
I think she's mostly talking about the
parodies that they do because for the
most part Marvel has been using Deadpool
in the comics as a mouthpiece to make
fun of a bunch of other pop culture
things so in the way that Rick and Morty
parody is a lot of sci-fi tropes I think
that the Deadpool series will do the
same thing for a lot of its own specific
genres the universe is at stake evil
they're the guardians of the unguarded
or the writers of their own press
releases Morty there are a bunch of
drama queens it's been an hour talking
and 20 minutes jumping around while [ __ ]
blows up they're a phase we did one it
was the big event of that summer so the
writer goes on to say that I love the
Deadpool character because he can't die
I mean for all intents and purposes I
think that he's like God in a way it's
sort of fun to play with a character who
can do anything basically and really get
into the mentality of someone who is
bored with life who doesn't feel any
stakes doesn't feel any danger and is
like okay it's just kind of my life and
I do what I do with being someone who
exists on a superior platform than
everybody else what would you do if you
lived forever couldn't die so obviously
Deadpool very different character from
Rick and Morty I would have never
connected those two in my head before
reading all these writers comments but
using him is sort of a mouthpiece to
parody and send up all these other
things that are happening sounds like
it'll be a lot of fun but I have a
feeling if they are gonna premiere this
series in May that means that a teaser
will probably drop sometime in the next
couple of months but like I said
animation takes a long time so it takes
a lot longer for them to cut a teaser
and because they're using the movie to
help promote the series it sounds like
they're gonna wait till after we get a
lot
our Deadpool 2 promos before we start
getting promos for the actual TV series
your time's up you dumb [ __ ] well that's
just lazy writing which I think
everybody is fine now like the really
big thing that I know everybody wants to
know though is is who is the voice cast
going to be what are their characters
going to be at the start is he gonna
have run of the Marvel Universe of
characters because there's like a whole
issue with TV rights like who has the
rights to the x-men characters on TV
versus the movies because it's not the
same thing as the film Universal like
Fox owns Deadpool all the x-men universe
characters Marvel owns pretty much
everything else at this point besides
spider-man even though Sony has that
sharing arrangement with them the
television rights are a completely
separate thing but the thing about
animated series is it's a lot easier for
them to use pretty much anybody you'd
want usually the live-action series are
the ones that have problems using those
really big characters DC is a good
example there's a lot of live-action DC
television shows they can't use Batman
Wonder Woman or Superman well maybe very
limited use of Superman but they've kind
of put the kibosh on that so you look at
cartoons like Young Justice though and
they can use pretty much every single
character that you could imagine from
the DC toy box so I'm wondering if it's
the same thing for this Deadpool
animated series because like you're not
gonna see certain characters interact
with Ryan Reynolds in the movies they're
just like not enough time for something
like that but you do a TV series and you
can have him run into all of the
mainstream x-men run into any of the
Avengers characters so no worries we'll
find out more about that really soon
but like I said maybe infinity war
footage coming tomorrow morning in there
is a new episode of wally west on
legends of tomorrow so i'll be posting
my video for that later tonight so just
look out for that but click here for
that last big Deadpool trailer and click
here for that big Captain America Black
Panther Easter egg thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]